smell a little bacon
we'll see look like you do a little bit
of push-ups I do I work out all right I
gotta stay here all right he was trained
by the force no what's your local
Precinct wait a minute I think it's the
40 the 45th Precinct yeah so you know
the precinct number so you did a lot of
training you worked out I did Academy
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu not Police Academy
so if I'm I'm going over here you know
how you're gonna take me down
I'm gonna get that wrist
oh then this will come over that way
that's like a cuff position right there
drive a car what type of car Hyundai
Elantra not an Impala no no you ever had
an Impala no I don't know you mad
suspicious really just quick to answer
everything I'm just spitting out what do
you have for breakfast three marble
lights and a coffee sounds like a
retired 80 cops excuse me yeah you heard
me a cop yep yeah okay okay